alright guys so as all of you know we're
expecting apple's imac line to finally
get redesigned after eight
very long years and i've been digging
deep into apple's future
custom mac silicon and i think i figured
out exactly what the redesigned
24 inch imac is gonna look like and yes
the 24 inch imac model is the one that
we should be expecting
either later this year or early next
year so let me quickly explain that
before we move on
all of the leaks and rumors are pointing
to apple's lower end max
getting apple silicon chips first like
the entry-level 12-inch macbook
and the 13-inch macbook pro this totally
makes sense because those macs are meant
for consumers
who run basic apps browse the web and
stream video
compared to the higher end macs which
are used for professional work
like the 27 inch imac that just got
refreshed with killer specs
and it's been performing very well in
all of our recent testing
now on the other hand the 21 and a half
inch imac model
didn't get updated with new specs for
the first time
in many years which is the nail in the
coffin
which confirms all the rumors of a 24
inch imac redesign
with apple silicon chips coming very
soon
specifically within the next seven
months so let's get into exactly what i
think the imac redesign will look like
and why it makes a whole lot of sense
and not just the 24 inch
but the larger model as well which is
rumored to be coming in the second half
of next year
with a custom apple gpu my speculations
on the redesign start all the way back
in 2011
with the older design of the imac as you
can see
the internals were packed to the brim
basically using
all of the available space they could
for things like the hard drive
the disk drive the speakers and much
more and from the side
you can tell that this was a pretty
thick imac and the year after that
apple redesigned it with a thinner body
that they're still
using in 2020 and as you can see
the internals are quite a bit smaller so
they decided to put larger speaker
enclosures
to fill the gaps now fast forward to
2020 and we now have a new teardown from
owc
that reveals similar internals but a
whole lot of extra room
now that they've gone away with the
physical hard drive
and just watch what happens when they
remove the speaker enclosures
most of the outdated imac case is still
being unused
now before i dig deep into the rest of
those internals
and what i believe is going to happen to
them on the apple silicon models
i want to switch over to what the new
design will look like on the exterior
way back in 2011 apple released the
27-inch
thunderbolt display to replace the apple
cinema display
then on october 20th of 2012 just
over a year later apple introduced the
fully redesigned imac
with an identical display with the same
aspect ratio
and the same resolution it looked almost
identical
except that the imac had a chin on the
bottom and then the 21.5 inch model
was basically the same except scaled
down now this brings us to june 3rd
2019 when apple revealed the pro display
xdr
that went on sale in december from the
front the rounded corners and black
bezels
look very similar to an ipad pro with
flat edges on the side
as well and when you're looking from the
side the pro display xtr
is quite a bit thick and that's because
the casing has the passive cooling vents
that are milled out of a solid block of
aluminum to match the mac pro's design
that adds extra thickness and it's a
high-end
multi-layer display that outputs a ton
of light
for hdr editing now if you've been
following the 24-inch imac redesigned
rumors
there were many leaks pointing to apple
redesigning the imac
with an ipad pro like design which is
basically what the pro display xdr
already looks like the only problem is
that the pro display xtr is a bit bulky
having thick sides and a large bulky
stand so here's what i think the
redesigned imac is gonna look like
and how apple is gonna achieve it on the
front side it'll look
just like the pro display xdr with the
same thin bezels
except that it'll have a chin on the
bottom with a small apple logo
why the chin well because the imac has
always had the chin it needs to have
the chin if the 2012 27 inch imac
didn't have a chin it would literally be
identical to the thunderbolt display
when looking at it from the front apple
needs to make sure
that when you see an imac you know it's
an imac and we do
because it's always had a chin and the
same thing goes for the redesigned apple
silicon imac
it's gonna have a chin with an apple
logo except that i think the chin is
gonna be a little bit smaller
but by how much i don't know but it'll
probably be smaller than the massive
chin
we currently have the sides of the imac
are going to be flat
just like the pro display xdr except
that i believe
the sides are actually going to be a bit
thinner now the
interesting part is that i think the
newly redesigned imac
is gonna have a totally flat back no
more hump like we have currently
on the imac it'll be flat just like the
pro display xdr
except that it won't have the same
cheese grater vents
now you might be asking how is apple
gonna fit the guts or the internals of
the imac
with it being thinner than the pro
display xdr and
not having a hump well first off the
hump design is not gonna work
with thick flat edges because that's
exactly how the 2011 imac look like
and apple won't be going back to that
design apple wants their new imac to
look modern
for a new modern apple silicon chip and
a new modern macos design and if you
think about it
all three of those things come from the
ipad pro
which looks modern with its flat sides
already has a modern apple silicon chip
and as you already know mac os big sur
looks a whole lot like ipad os 14.
so apple is going all in with the new
rounded corner
and flat edge look which is exactly what
the iphone 12 is gonna look like
as well the ipad air 4 is also rumored
to be taking on the same design
as the current ipad pro this makes sense
for apple to do because this transition
is a massive one
and by the time it's finished all of
apple's flagship devices
are going to look very similar design
wise now getting back to how apple can
fit all of those internals in a flat
and thin imac this brings us to that
teardown of the 2020 imac
from owc this right here is the guts of
the current 27-inch imac
which is now smaller this year because
the hard drive is now gone
since it comes with an ssd at the base
price
it's absolutely tiny compared to the
size of the imac
now of course this is the 27 inch model
but this logic board
without the hard drive is also now
pretty small in the 21 and a half inch
model as well
now here is that same imac with the
power supply removed
it becomes even smaller now once it
takes out the main board and flips it
over
we see the reason for the hump on the
imac there are two
quite large heat sinks one for the cpu
and one for the graphics chip
and along with that we have the user
upgradable ram
that sticks out quite a bit so it makes
sense why apple used this design
in the 2012 imac and now let's finally
get into the design of the apple silicon
imac
and how it can easily have thin sides
and a completely flat back
if you've watched some of my videos on
the apple silicon chips
you'll know that they're designed to run
very efficiently
using much less power than intel chips
and you'll also know that apple is
ditching the amd
gpu and going with their own custom
apple gpu
which will be integrated into the main
soc so let's take a look at that logic
board again
on the apple silicon max there obviously
won't be
a hard drive which is already missing on
the current imac
with apple silicon that huge power
supply on the left side
is going away since the graphics will be
integrated into the main soc
we no longer need all of that space for
that chip on the right side
or its massively thick heatsink and
since apple silicon is going to be more
efficient
the socketed intel cpu and its thick
heatsink
is going away it'll likely have a much
thinner cooling design
like on the 16-inch macbook pro and the
large fan
no longer needs to be that large anymore
they can make it thinner
and more spread out thanks to all that
extra space
the user-replaceable ram that is also
quite a bit thick is most likely going
away which is a bit sad
but it makes sense for an apple silicon
chip which integrates everything
into one soc now if you think about it
everything is going to be soldered onto
the main board
the apple silicon chip the ram the
storage
and the power supply will be built in
the cooling system will be much smaller
than before since there's no need
for a dedicated graphics ship that takes
a huge amount of power
and the apple silicon chip itself takes
much less power than an intel cpu
basically the main board is going to be
much thinner than before
and all of the leftover empty space can
be filled up by the speaker enclosures
which will be thinner and more spread
out so it totally makes sense for the
guts of the imac to fit into a chassis
that's thinner than the pro display xdr
and finally
i think the stand is going to look very
similar to the one on that display
which is already shaped like an ipad pro
except that the stand will obviously be
included for the same price and
permanently attached to the back
like on the current imac so there you
guys have it that's my speculation for
the redesigned imac
it'll look just like the pro display xdr
with the same rounded corners
the same thin bezels except with a chin
that's likely going to be smaller than
the current one the sides will be flat
and it'll be thinner overall with a flat
back the 24 inch imac will get it first
probably within the next seven months
and then the larger imac will likely get
the redesign
in the second half of next year if you
agree with my speculation on the
redesign
let me know down in the comment section
below and be sure to check out our apple
product merch like our arm
apple silicon t-shirt or our mask down
in the merch shelf below
and if you can't wait to see this new
imac redesign click the circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one